[Music]
it's this close now it's grenade
distance the two sides aren't even 30
meters
[Applause]
this is apocalyptic stuff it's one step
away from hand-to-hand combat in
virtually you'll never see this type of
thing in modern warfare because this
isn't it's as many evil as the ruins
these tiny streets are now a
battleground as fierce as anything we've
seen absolutely nowhere is safe Islamic
state could be on the floor below or the
house next door you have much greater
speed now
the Federal Police are closing in on the
last is positions where possible they go
through walls rather than risk the
streets
sometimes though there is no choice the
only option is to run across the gaps
[Applause]
snipers try to pick off is fighters
moving in the rubble below and it is
rubble this ancient city is being
destroyed incredibly people are still
here
thousands unable to escape until
liberation comes old ladies emerge into
their Street shuffling up the road whole
families come forward to be greeted by
the troops this ordeal is done but
surviving in camps is an ordeal as well
there's a constant hand-delivered supply
of water and food to the frontlines up
and down in and out of the center
it's baking hot the fighting is intense
and they're exhausted if you believe the
Iraqis could show this resolve
it seems the end is now near the
soldiers are confident that the old city
is going to be there very shortly these
guys are just coming from the front
which is behind us here what is certain
though of course is the huge number of
civilian casualties that happened as a
result of this fighting and of course
the old city is now pretty much
destroyed the Islamic state fighters
left here will die and they'll try to
take as many people with them as they
can their time here is ending
still antis can use in Mosel zob city